hi everyone in this video I have a talk
about T cell differentiation so in this
video what I would do is first give you
an idea about briefly how T cell develop
and where do they develop after
development how do they differentiate
into several subtypes and what are the
factors that then that help the T cells
to get differentiated into separate
identities and I would discuss the
details about the signaling and the
genetic aspect to it so stay tuned and
watch the video till the end and if you
haven't subscribed to my channel please
subscribe and hit the bell icon so such
that you can get notification whenever I
upload a video so let's start so our
body has one primary lymphoid organ
known as thymus now thymus is a training
school of T cell where T cell develops
actually so in the bone marrow of T cell
forms and you know immature state they
go to their school which is the thymus
thymus is just a training school for T
cell just like an army training school
what the Army's learn several tactics
and become our army now after thymic
selection what happens is T cells are
becoming two different type of T cells
one is cd8 for positive T cells and
other is cd8 positive T cells the cd8
positive T cells are known as hyper and
the helper T cells which are able to
recognize the peptides bound to class 2
images where as silly 8 positive T cells
or cytotoxic T cells which are destined
to identify the peptides in the class 1
MHC now after they have their fate is
kind of determined they migrate into a
secondary lymph node a secondary
lymphoid organ which is live not only
lymph node is just like a army camp to
it so that in army camp army stayed
there for kind of a four particular
period for and and wait there until any
kind of Massacre happens so
there are distant region inside the
lymph node were b-cell and t-cell recite
so definitely the t-cells reside in the
para cortex which could be thought as
specific Barack's insider army P Army
gap now dendritic cell which are kind of
compared to a patrolling police officer
would go to this so-called army base and
let the t-cell knows about what type of
pathogen has invaded and according to
that T cells would prepare how to fight
for that sort of Hull fight for that
infection and they would kind of they
would kind of divide themselves into
small platoons and these small platoons
are actually several subtypes of the T
cells now for example a pathogen here
which is a pathogen associated molecular
pattern here which is could be a portion
of the bacterial flagella could be a
portion of the bacterial lipid or
anything could be detected by specific
antigen present presenting cells such as
dendritic cells or it could be also
alternatively detected by macrophages
all by specific surface bound toll-like
receptors now specific specifically
these dendritic cells which are kind of
like a patrolling police officer would
go to the base camp that means in the
lymph node and interact with the T cell
and depending upon what type of
polarizing cytokine they are secreting
this naive T helper cell would
differentiate into several subcategories
for example now in this picture you can
see that depending upon the polarizing
cytokine the naive cd8 the Knife cd4
positive helper T cell can either
differentiate into th one sub category
or th two sub category so the
determining factor is thus polarizing
cytokine but what governs that what type
of polarizing cytokine would be secreted
the secretion of
DeWine is kind of based upon what type
of infection had happened let me give an
example for example a virus has invaded
a cell and the virus also is detected
the viral deist RNA is let's say
detected by intracellular TLR tlr3 which
signals in turn inside the dendritic
cell to produce a lot of interleukin 12
now once interleukin 12 here works like
a polarizing cytokine in order for this
naive t-cell to get activated it
requires at least two signal and a third
modulated signal the first signal comes
from the viral proteins or anything
which is displayed on the surface by
class 2 MHC that is actually recognized
by t-cell receptor which gives a
signaling to to the nucleus second a
cd28
on the naive T cell and up cd8 T or cd8
T six on the dendritic T cell have an
interaction that give rise a second
signal and a third signal comes from
il-12 and il-12 receptor mediated
signaling now this third signal works
downstream via stacked four
phosphorylated stat 4 goes to the
nucleus and transcribes master regulated
genes like debate now in this situation
il-2 mediated signaling ultimately allow
the expression of master regulated t bit
the debate is work like a stable switch
it can switch between the T cells can
switch between alternative sub phases or
alternative sub states by expressing
this particular gene so once T very
things expressed their faith is switch
towards th one positive self another
example let's say the infecting
substance is a helmet that is in turn
detected which ultimately give rise to a
Taylor mediated signal to nucleus such
that the general
secrete interleukin 4 and interleukin 4
works like a differentiating polarizing
cytokine which would allow our naive
t-cell to express gen3
instead of T bet that would switch the
fit towards a th2 type of cd8 positive
cells not a th one so depending upon
what type of polarizing cytokine is
present and also what type of master
regulator is expressed and the source of
infection or the type of invaded
invasion based on all these three the
factors in all these three factors
determine how a t-cell would
differentiate further into subcategories
now here is an overall example that how
different polarizing cytokine can give
rise to different subpopulations or
several subcategories of t-cell for
example the master gene expression is
very important for example for a th
positive cell T beta expression is most
important whereas in case of th17 cell
rawrr gamma t is very important
Mustard's regulated chain for example th
to get a three and fourteen regulatory
cell Fox p3 is a very important master
regulator gene so all this master
regulated gene expression determines
that what would be the fate of that sub
population of the T cell so that is how
a particular naive cd4 t-cell helper T
cell becomes several subcategories of
the T cell and it is mostly determined
the cytokines that's why cytokine
signaling is very important for T cell
differentiation I hope you enjoyed this
video and it was informative to you if
you liked my video give it a quick
thumbs up please don't forget to share
subscribe and thank you